[Music]
joining me today is British author
journalist and political commentator
Douglas Murray he is also the associate
director of the Henry Jackson Society
and associate editor of The Spectator
Douglas welcome to the Rubin report very
good to be with him to see you in person
I don't know how we haven't done this in
person yeah I didn't haven't been
another it's yeah what in God's name are
you doing living anywhere else besides
LA well it's it's actually not my
favourite bit of America I have to say I
find it's slightly uncentered and
rootlets also I don't drive so la is
sort of hell because you can't walk
anywhere but well I know you're not
making that up because you were stuck on
a plane for about four hours last night
you arrived at like 2:00 a.m. then we
tried to send a car to get you this
morning that took some time as long as
if it's me being difficult but now I
actually managed to watch the three
films before the plane even took off
last night yes New York anything good
no-oh-oh ever I don't watch many films
they're all bad yes always bad almost
always bad do you feel you're at your
intellectual best right now because you
didn't get much sleep are you ready to
do this I depends that rigor as you want
to be yeah well I've got some very
rigorous questions right here but I
think that's an interesting way to kick
off because you're somebody that you
know everything that I that I see you
right and the events that you speak at
and the talks that you give and all that
stuff I mean you have to be at your
intellectual best pretty much all the
time I don't know if you feel you always
are but but what kind of pressure does
that put you under just to be to be one
of the people that you know you have to
have a cohesive set of thoughts and be
able to defend them all the time I'm not
sure you have to have no um I tell you
what I mean I don't admire okay I don't
envy politicians for having to have the
thing of having to turn up say their I
think never beat off message and all
that sort of thing I kind of feel that
you know I'm a writer I can I can have
bad days I can change my mind on things
I can nuance things
texture things or I can be garbled one
and you know nobody says oh my god he's
a total train wreck I don't know I don't
know if they did I wouldn't care but
well it's funny you say that cuz right
before we started we were talking about
social media a little bit you were
saying how you you don't respond that
often or pay too much attention to that
and not on Facebook I'm on Twitter I use
Twitter as a way to communicate to the
few people who care you know anything I
write or appear on but I don't talk to
the world as it were I don't think it's
doable I think it drives people mad I've
seen some of the least you know
relatively promising minds of my
generation slightly wrecked by a social
media yeah you know you wouldn't you
wouldn't seek out people to shout at you
on the street so you wouldn't if they
did say come over here it's like your
basis and do it when I wake up and
turnover in the morning and tell my
phone on yeah so I do think that people
have to find a sort of reasonable way to
live in this strange strange world which
is even stranger than a hey obviously
yeah well it'sit's much stranger in LA
and we are going for dinner tonight I'm
gonna show you how weird it can get even
think you know what's weird in LA I'm
gonna I'm gonna really show you tonight
tell me a little bit so we've done this
once before and it was about two years
ago and I had just started doing an
interview show and we we talked about a
lot of the problems that we both had
with the left and the rise of Islam and
some of that we're gonna cover here but
I thought maybe we could just talk about
a little bit about your history first
and what kind of brought you to be one
of the one of the few people that is so
outspoken on some of these issues what
what made you care about the free speech
stuff about what's happening in the West
all of this stuff when did that really
spark in you um it's hard I mean these
things are easier to recognize in other
people than they are in yourself I've
written about a lot of different things
in my life I started writing very young
they became I became a published author
so I wrote my first book when I was 18
it came out and I was 19 or 20 I think
and that was on literature and I
literally figure and then I started
writing about politics and the one thing
which somebody once said to me about me
is it was I
I thought was probably somewhere near
the truth was somebody once said that I
had a very low tolerance threshold for
lies and I think there is something in
that I genuinely maybe it will wear out
at some point but people just overdose
as it were on lies but right I just I
find I don't like being told lies and I
don't like cute about historical think
that's my first book partly about it I
think it's a set of historical
misunderstandings that had happened in
relation with the figure I was writing
about and I wanted to correct them and
then in politics of course if you have a
low tolerance threshold for lies maybe
it's just not the right yeah that was my
next question maybe you picked an odd
thing to be writing without got into
surfing or something I don't know but
yeah but it but politic politics and
political lies you know galvanizes me
and I suppose the other thing is that
I'm I'm not a political nut I'm not I
don't really care who's running in that
district for which part in which you
know party they voted for four years ago
and I sort of think is interesting it's
not what I spent my life feeling taking
pressed or you know enamored with but I
do I do think that if you care about the
culture in the widest sense as I do then
you've got to be interested in politics
you you've got to take some attitude
towards it and they say not not in order
you further your political goals or
something you want to do that it should
really be a politician but I think in
order to try to safeguard the coach I
mean I mean I don't even mean the coach
I mean really to safeguard the practice
of culture oh yeah and then that's what
politics seems to me to be very largely
for um I'm quite interested in taxation
I'm not very interested in it I just
want the circumstances to be right for
the culture to thrive yeah so when
people say oh you know I'm not a
political person or something like that
I hate that phrase because it really
what are you actually saying you look
like you're either pretending that
you're above it or you somehow don't
need it and yet politics you're right
it's about creating the conditions so
that you can do all of the other things
you care I think what people what a lot
of people mean when they say that
I'm not a party person I'm not going to
bore on about the Labour Party or
concerta party or the Democrats or the
Republicans I think that's what what
people Amin but in any case a lot of
people who said that sometime ago don't
say that anymore
in fact that maybe the more they said in
the past they weren't a politics person
the more now they're shrieking and
gibbering and storming yeah do you think
there's a danger in that so we had all
these people that you know whatever that
whatever that meant to them they weren't
politics people but now everybody's
shrieking and screaming and everyone's
in the part of it that you just said
that doesn't really do it for you that
piece of the day-to-day racehorse stuff
and that's why I try to focus on the
philosophical right because the the
who's running for this or all of that
stuff yes it's important at some level
but it's the bigger picture stuff that I
think really matters yes and you know to
a great extent in your country and in
mine there is a type of person now who I
think has got politics all the wrong way
around
I mean maybe it is as I say people who
didn't pay much attention to it in the
past but there are people who are now I
think putting onto politics an amount of
weight that it can't bear yeah it's
about their entire existence as it were
and I wouldn't want that to be the case
at all I mean I you know I had with a
colleague some time ago sort of informal
competition of the Conservative Party
won the 2015 election in Britain had an
informal competition to say you know
what's the nuttiest thing anyone said
and the best was it his woman at the
Guardian who wrote a column saying that
basically she cried herself to sleep
every night and she woke up in the
morning crying and she sometimes she
stopped time she woke up and she thought
oh my god I've had a nightmare no it's
true and then she burst into tears again
that person shouldn't really be in the
community should they right but if I I
mean I you know I have views I'm who I
want to win and any one time which party
I'd vote for but but I cannot imagine
any scenario in which I became such a
gibbering wreck that I've just wept all
the time or because she might not have
been telling the truth this this corner
right or thought it wise to
say to people that's the state I'm in
right right well it shows her victimhood
she's such a video she can't sleep the
best is when you see the Huffington Post
or one of these pieces probably in The
Guardian to where it's not just them
that are crying their children yeah
waking up having nightmares about mom my
three-year-olds having a nightmare about
drumming mommy what they say what can i
what should I tell my three-year-old but
now he's asking about trauma again I
know I tend to go to sleep you know it's
so funny I tweeted this out a couple
months ago but when when in the middle
of the election you know all these
articles are being ready to kick how
trump is affecting kids this morning so
I asked I asked my my at the time I
think he was five or six my nephew I
said what do you what do you know about
Donald Trump he looks at me he's like he
has bad hair and a red tie I was like
that's what again that's what a kid
would think all right so I want to talk
about your book but I thought before we
get inside I want to do a little bit
more on just sort of language in general
and the free speech thing so when you
come to America because we have some
extra protections for now at least on
free speech that you guys across Europe
don't have do you feel an extra degree
of freedom you don't strike me as
someone that ever bites your tongue but
when you come here and know that we have
such a great for you or do you see
something a little different here
perhaps I think you do I mean I I think
you just gotta separate out between the
what your legal rights are as it were
what the actual practice is these days
yes legally I mean there's nothing I say
that's illegal in Britain or Europe and
so I don't particularly feel freer to
say anything here exist nothing I would
say here I would say there and vice
versa it's true that you're having an
amendment your constitution that
actually writes this in a law is a very
useful thing to have
we've course don't even have a
constitution in Britain which has its
own advantages and problems but but I
think these things have to be slightly
divorced on the reality of the practice
as is at the moment and at the moment I
think you're probably you know
worse situation than we are in Britain
or Europe in relation to speech mainly
because of a generation of people who
are growing up and the most privileged
generation in history who seemed to
think that speech is violence and that
in response to violence you should be
violent and if you make that leap then
the response to somebody speaking is to
hit them and oughta shut them down or to
burn a building or to get them killed or
whatever you want and I see that all the
time all over the place somebody I know
in Holland who there's a couple weeks
ago lot of people in the press of him
demonizing him and then says house was
attacked two nights ago and I'm Saddam
and there's lots of that going on loads
of loads of target selection and and I
think I think all this is very very
worrying but I I do think that in
general you you seem in America to make
terrible generalization do we slightly
further down the road of certain manias
about this it seems to embedded itself
more this idea of being wounded or even
hurt by words and and yeah and you've
got all of the SJW stuff slightly worse
I think yeah it do you think that maybe
just that in and of itself could be just
a cultural thing that Americans kind of
scream about things more were hysterical
you guys are a little more polite I was
asking a friend in New York about this
the other day it's I wonder whether the
you know that thing you always hear in
America this is the most important
election of our lifetime every single
one yeah and it's always I mean by the
way I'm fascinated by the language
hyperventilation in this country and I
was fascinated by that moment before the
last election when Bill Maher said look
we called Senator McCain the misogynist
and I we were just he doing it try to
get him and we we're like noisy wasn't
and then we did it on him and then we
were he wasn't but it Romney wasn't
really misogynist but now this guy is so
I'm fascinated by this thing of
basically a lot of sort of chickens
coming home to roost in some ways you
kept running the language down and now
you're in this position but I said it's
friend America the other day maybe that
the V as it were the hyperventilation of
politics is one of the ways in which you
keep your democracy fresh I mean maybe
you have to live for that pitch I mean I
wouldn't particularly want to live at it
myself all the time but perhaps the kind
of this is always the most important
moment ever is important for this
democracy maybe it's better than the
sort of doesn't really matter or ya
never gonna be as good as that again
that's a really ruminate on that a
little because I think you can argue it
both ways I think I mean it's why you're
saying you can I can see a problem with
that level of hysteria all the time and
you're right when when Bill Maher said
that and oh yeah yeah the left was
saying all these horrible things about
McCain we did it about McCain we did
about Romney this is the real one
well you've cried wolf to the point now
that what did you expect to happen in an
odd way is that is that a pro Trump
argument strangely like he was of course
what was gonna happen here you know what
I mean like you tried it with you tried
it with some decent sort of center right
people right but of course you're gonna
get this then right maybe maybe I'm
resistant myself to the introducing
Donald Trump will miss any discussion
after they almost always derails after
and after almost everything that happens
in the UK and recent in the last year or
so okay well how will this affect Donald
Trump just stop talking about them to
say allow other things in the world to
exist yeah as well so you're saying when
I think you're Mayor of London we're
saying we don't want Trump to come here
you'd be okay if Trump showed up right I
think that's a just thing Donald Trump
has made an official visit to Paris yeah
he's made official visits to Germany to
a tourist so quite a lot of Allied
countries by now I think yeah I think
it's outrageous and I think people
should protest if they want to protest
but and I remember the protests against
George W Bush when he came to London and
during his presidency and there was
there some very very Vermont protests
but
I don't my people for testing of course
right but I just I think this attempt to
say I mean our most important ally and
particularly an important time in our
national history in Britain we need to
be reforming our alliances and renewing
them to say eff off to the president of
your closest ally seems to me to be very
very unwise as well as as rude yeah
is it one of those things where it's
just it's it's just the easy answer you
know just out all that I'm here will it
shows how good we are don't let it here
but actually what you do you're actually
do damage to probably the most important
you know a relationship that these
countries have salutely I mean when the
Mayor of London says we don't want him
in London yeah well well he's in Paris
he's in Berlin like what have you
achieved at the best you will you'll
damage among other things the economic
relations between Britain and America so
nice work mr. mayor
nice work right right all right so we're
almost we're almost at your book so I
thought this is the good transition here
I was listening to I think it was you're
not your last discussion with Sam Harris
maybe the one before that and you were
guys we're talking about language and
sort of the slow erosion of what's
happening in the West and the rise of
Islam a lot of the key stuff that we all
kind of talked about and you were
talking about how we're gonna be arguing
about gender pronouns as all of our
rights are going to be taken away from
us you said it far more eloquently and
with some better adjectives but I
thought it was a really interesting
point that our our eye is not on the
prize no in that we're not focusing on
what's really important I'm worried
about things that are not to say trans
gender rights aren't important but
they're they're not the big pictures
know how important is all of that
focusing on the right things
I think it's crucial I mean people can
be interested in whatever they like but
I also have the right to time I think
they're wasting their lives agenda
pronouns all this sort of thing these
this is there is by the way behind all
this something very strange I started to
notice there among all the fascinating
things about this one of the ones that
interests me most
why you get this this this introduction
to almost every discussion as if we as
human beings are sort of solvable things
I find this fascinating most of the
trans stuff is you know identify that
you're of the wrong gender at an early
stage by the way I'm very suspicious
about all that but I think can think of
a lot of effeminate young men who
shouldn't have drugs even encouraged
towards them yeah when you say that you
mean you're suspicious of the way we're
treating them or of the sort of
psychological sight because the the
psychological thing in general but let's
say in a case of somebody actually does
genuinely feel that they are in the
wrong body and so on that there's this
awful thing in it as in so many other
discussions at the moment of and if you
Nix that you you'll be on you'll be
right mm-hmm and I think no no no once
you you sort that out you'll face all
the same problems everyone else faces in
their lives and maybe some new ones but
this this is I hear this in the race
discussion in America I hear it in the
gay discussion in America in in a whole
set of them it's as if it's as if if we
get the formula right and see I I just
think this is a fascinating mistake I
don't think we live our lives as solved
or solvable beings and and we are we are
engaged it's usefully in particularly in
this society in America in this strange
attempt to sort of get it the my new
Shai right and apart from being deeply
navel-gazing okay it seems likely to me
that that we may be missing all the
really important things that are going
on I have this sort of haunting view
always that we all feel like we've
really sorted out every aspect of LGBTQI
rights just as China becomes the most
important power in the world very
interesting right an interesting yeah I
think it's a fascinating piece because I
was gonna ask I was gonna talk a little
bit more
this at the end but you're gay and I
asked you in our last interview right at
the end by that fact alone how much does
that give you an extra sensitivity to
all of the other things that you're
talking about you have a vested interest
you and I and I think yeah all of us I
think all humans all together have a
vested interest in keeping the West or I
sure but I think as a gay person it's
particularly important that the last
places of tolerance and Western thought
are kept alive yes I have to say my in
case that's not particularly a
galvanizing thing I have to say I mean I
think being gay is kind of boring as a
subject from the way because certainly
for my generation I mean we sort of came
out it came out and by your twenties
right who wants to keep going on about
that albeit I understand of white people
did before but you know you there's not
a career or life as it were and just
being a gay you know I mean it's not a
full-time occupation so many of us can
be in reality TV there's only so many
fashion gigs on Bravo
and I so I've never I've never picked
and it's never particularly influenced
my politics and in fact I may have said
to you before I'm generally very opposed
to the idea of politics being about what
am I myself and how can I get the world
to most accommodate itself towards me
mm-hmm
I think it's certainly mistake having
politics should be search for some kind
of truth or the best arrangement that
allows the truth to occur and you know
your own involvement in it or your own
comfort in it is of importance but it I
mean I wouldn't want somebody said I'm
totally into this because I'm fighting
for myself and that's it in fact whether
we're sorry since you mention it on some
of this stuff on the Islam sufferance
it's actually the first warning sound to
me was not dreamed of gays I was dreamed
of Jews which I became sort of
increasingly noticing there was a
problem a couple of decades ago now but
um it was that I'm sure how how are you
sir - in Britishness well I was I was
worried about it because I started to
notice that there were things that were
being said that I thought wouldn't come
round again and
judge myself that you can you can notice
these things and and not need to as it
were have a personal vested interest in
in it you know and I mean I suppose one
other thing I said is I I generally
think I mean the atomization of society
into groups with their own interests is
one of the things that's causing that
all this mess in America at the moment I
don't see why the job of gays should be
just to sort of fight for the gays and
the job of the Jews should be to fight
for the Jews and and so on and so forth
I think I think the idea of sort of
looking out for each other is surely the
point in a republic and yet that point
seems to be lost right so is that where
this this intersectional crew has really
lost it because they said they're sort
of getting what you're saying that we
should be looking out for each other
that should bring all of these minority
groups together except instead of that
they're vying for me depressed the vibe
might suppress and most ridiculous and
most hyperventilating and all of that
but the intersectionality people I mean
there's two big things one is they are
the prime culprits of this thing of the
myth of solvability the myth of humans
our ability right if we just if we get
the Rubik's Cube right and okay the
games get there then we get the trans in
and then there's people here and the
non-binary love this and then and then
the Muslims get there and we could all
think exactly they can all think exactly
the same and speak in exactly the
preferential order that without speaking
it will all be fine with my view is
you'll still have every single problem
of the world ahead of you you'll still
have to work out where your foreign
policy is a whole load of stuff is
coming but so that's that's the first
thing but the second thing is they are
obviously breaking apart American
society I don't think that's too much of
an exaggeration because they started at
the universities and it's trickling
across everything else and I've been
having really interesting conversations
with people about this in recent years
in Europe as well as in America and one
of the things I'm sort of slightly
confident about here in America isn't
you do have an answer to it and it's an
answer you've had before you know the
problem of the identity politics thing
is we're already starting to see that
apart from being wrong in itself
and I think morally suspicious and
selfish you can't stop what you're gonna
create on it you can't have racial
rights for every group and racial pride
rights every group and always hold back
white you know pride whatever mm-hmm you
just you just can't at some point is
gonna break
you can't keep bashing heterosexual men
and not expect at some point that
there's gonna be some kind of response
so if everyone's allowed their group
apart from the majority or whatever then
at some point that's gonna get nasty and
I can see it coming
so clearly yeah I mean we see it now and
it's already started and the thing is
that in America you had the answer to
this which is what Tocqueville mentions
it's it's that the deal of being in the
Republic is you don't do that you you
deal with each other face face to face
as citizens you don't you don't do it as
just people coming to hawk something in
the marketplace but face to face as
individual citizens in the Republic and
this this is the only way out but I
think they'll obviously be some mania
before you get back there again yeah you
know it's funny you get that may you get
back a week yeah versus I'm a you know
it's funny the way I do the show I try
not to talk about individual people too
much because I'd always rather focus on
the ideas but as you're saying this I'm
thinking of something very specifically
that Linda Sarsour who I'm sure you're
know I spent an evening with in this
also in Brooklyn really yeah yeah that
go before a I tell you I think we got on
roaring Lee I said some man you guys I
know how to write was a bit of sexual
tension in the room unavoidable but no
the the fact he's actually she and we're
asked to debate the croc fandom word
Islamophobia at the Brooklyn Art Museum
and I like a challenge and I think our
mutual friend ayaan Hirsi Ali was also
meant to be there but I think
various things happened the garland
shooting happened and it was decided it
wasn't safe yarn I still did it and
things but yeah the whole thing that he
started off with the other side sort of
giggling about the fact that they saw
ray arm we couldn't even turn up you
know it was all using it against her and
Diane's afraid of anybody
yeah and and yeah and I and I said yes I
think countenance I saw before she
became as it were infamous and I thought
she was a very nasty very bitter very
unamerican actually I just say that
because she she knows like all
demagogues how to introduce herself and
introduce herself to some proud Brockton
I to proud American a proud Palestinian
accept Osetra no and I thought in an
interesting order but it was clear that
she sort of really hated America or at
least hates America that exists
currently because I was me that ended up
having to explain to the audience that
for instance the New York police don't
just go around persecuting Muslims you
know it's just a willful
misrepresentation of of the American
authorities at every turn so I thought
she was very dishonest very unpleasant
and but I mean I've come across her type
all my life yeah and the only reason I
mention her is because of what you said
previously which really was about
assimilation that the whole point of
America is to assimilate and I don't
know if you saw that speech she gave
about two months ago where she called
for a ji-hye and suddenly the left was
defending the word jihad and the white
supremacist in the in the White House
and all that but I thought the key part
of it put jihad aside put white
supremacy aside the key part was when
she said we're not here to assimilate
yes I thought what a that is the
antithesis of the American project this
amazing melting pot that we have where
we've done for the most part
multicultural right multiculturalism
right where Europe has failed in a lot
of ways and she was saying no no
absolutely and I thought that was more
dangerous than the others absolutely of
course I mean me as you said I mean put
aside I know the fantastical idea that
what she was suggesting was you know you
sort of have a jihad by kind of going
and just really in a struggling in front
of it you know I I'm just struggling in
front of this Israeli
I'm having a turmoil yeah that yeah this
is this is what I recognized the night
we met I mean she really doesn't like
this country by the way I mean we all
have a problem by that what you what you
do about that
mmm it seems to me she's a sort of very
rabid sectarian sort of Palestinian
nationalist who happens to live in
Brooklyn but I mean really what you do
about it is that people identified that
recognizes and called out for what it
was what it is and they just aren't
there many people who do that still I
mean that you know we all take sort of
baby steps on this don't we know as you
saying now you end up with the left so
defending Welsh even problem in this and
it you just say look she's not speaking
as a critic of our society who wants to
sort of mildly improve it she's speaking
as an opponent of our society because
she doesn't like it mm-hmm
I've encountered this I say all my life
in my opponents and the very close
enemies I've made in Britain and across
Europe a certain type of person of that
ilk who clearly speaks as an opponent of
the society they don't like it and of
course among other things all you can do
is point to point out then is to say you
know amazing your hair really isn't it
amazing yeah and that's the catch-22 of
what we've got in the West right we're
gonna have to let in all sorts of voices
that's that's the beauty of this thing
and it also creates a little bit of the
bread
[Music]
you